y de esa euforia inicial de conocerse
los resultados se ha pasado ahora la
expectación porque se está esperando que
lleguen gustavo petro el presidente
electo de colombia y plantea márquez la
vicepresidenta electa de colombia a esta
sede para dar un discurso aquí a los
militantes congresistas y todas las
personas que se han congregado nos
comentaban también que habría la
posibilidad de ir en algún momento a la
plaza de oliver pero mientras tanto
también la gente está intentando
pasárselo bien con gritos de sí se pudo
también del pueblo unido jamás será
vencido' se ven banderas de colombia
también de m19 la guerrilla que se
disolvió ya hace más de 30 años ya la
que perteneció gustavo petro y también
una pancarta grande que pone el pueblo
es superior a sus dirigentes lluís qué
significa este resultado histórico en
colombia
histórico lo hemos ido diciendo durante
semanas ya en 13 de marzo cuando el
pacto histórico fue la primera fuerza en
ganar legislativas la puerta izquierda
en ganar unas legislativas también la
primera vuelta cuando gustavo petro y
frente a marketing también se impusieron
el número de votos y ahora en esta
segunda vuelta que les va a dar la
presidencia a gustavo petro un ex
guerrillero ya francia market un
afrodescendiente también la primero en
la historia que fue líder ambiental y se
ve en esas reacciones también en las
redes gabriel boric el presidente de
izquierda de chile ya le ha felicitado
también xiomara castró la presidenta de
honduras y asimismo también iván duque
el actual presidente de colombia hasta
el 7 de agosto cuando tomará posesión
gustavo petro